difference between the two so with a minor mistake it's a very very small
thing so say we're doing a outer block if it's not your shoulder height maybe
it's a little bit lower or maybe it's a tiny bit higher that's a minor mistake
so that's a 0.1 a major mistake would be you're supposed to do an outer block in
the pattern but you forget and you say you do a reach hand strike instead so
that would be a major mistake so with a minor mistake let's say pattern one for
example there's about 20 steps it's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14 15
mistakes in the 20 patterns sorry the 20 steps so the reason for that one being
it needs to be absolutely perfect to get to not get a deduction of 0.1 so it's not
uncommon to let's say there's 20 steps and you made 15 mistakes so what would
that be?
so we'll do that there on this side and we'll come back and we'll just
calculate the score at the end so major mistake say you're supposed to turn to
the left when you turn to the right that would be a major mistake so obviously we
do want to try and avoid any of these major mistakes so after we've done our
pattern that's when we move on to the presentation side so the presentation as
you can see it's from a score of 6 this 6 is actually split up into 3 parts so we
can do it here so with this one for a score of 2 is your power and speed your
rhythm is also a score of 2 and your expression of energy is also scored out
of 2 as well so we'll start off with the power and speed so with this one whether
it's your blocks your kicks your strikes your punches anything you are that you
do you need to be nice and strong and it has to be fast as well so that it's one
thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch
but it has to be both strong and fast to get high in that in that category the
next part is your rhythm so the rhythm when you do start your pattern there is a
rhythm to the pattern it's not just really fast all the way through it's not
slow all the way through there's a slow fast slow fast kind of aspect to it as
well so you do need to kind of work on your rhythm and that's also scored out
of 2 the last bit is your expression of energy so what is
expression of energy so that's basically how loud you shout so how much
intensity you have during your pattern as well so say you're doing your pattern
really well it's really fast and it's strong your rhythm is really great but
you're not shouting very loud or you can kind of tell the judges can kind of tell
oh you're not really confident you're a little bit nervous so that's why we need
to kind of improve on on as well so I'll just come around to this side so with
this one
color belts and black belts it's actually scored a little bit differently
so if you're a color belt you'll actually uh your average so where where
the judges actually mark you from it's actually from a 1.1 so this is your
average so say you did uh you did all right you did average compared to
everyone else your score for one two and three it'll start from a 1.1 so if
you're less than average in the judges eyes you might go down to
say for your power and speed you might get a one or even at 0.9 if you did really
great you might even get a 1.3 or 1.4 so each individual uh category you need to
obviously get as high as you can if you're a black belt generally depending
on the competition you will be scored from a 1.3 so 1.3 would be your average
view start from so say your current speed uh was above average uh average you might get scored a
1.4 for now. Say your rhythm was only about average. It wasn't amazing. It might be just
a 1.3. But let's say you didn't shout very loud. So your expression of energy, your average
was 1.3. It might drop to say, let's say a 1.0. So with this one, we'll come over down
to this side. So with this one, as I was saying, it's a total of 10. So let's see.
And for presentation, we had 1.7, 1, 2, 3. So you had a 3.7. And so you made 15 mistakes.
So with this one, obviously, don't be too discouraged if you do get pretty high in your
mistakes. This is with the judges. We have 3.
3 judges usually at the panel. And each judge, obviously, is very subjective. So from their
point of view, you might have made a lot of mistakes or you may have made not a lot of
mistakes as well. So that's why we have the 3 judges and we average it out as well.
Okay, so say we did our 15 mistakes, various 4 mistakes. So if they're all minus 0.1, it'd
be 1.5. So you go 4.3.
1.0 minus 1.5, which equals 2.5. So this would be your accuracy score. So with our
presentation like before, we're saying we've got a 3.7 here. So we add these numbers after
the judges are finished scoring. So you would get for this pattern, a 6.2, which is actually
very good. So I'll just talk about a little bit more now about this number here. So I'm
going to show you how to do this. So if you're a color belt, if you're a yellow or above
and you do your patterns, it's not uncommon. Generally, for a color belt, the average is
about a 4 to 5. So if you get a number between 4 and 5 out of 10 for your pattern, that's
actually generally considered pretty good. So anything above that, you can consider yourself
pretty good.
1.5.
2.5.
3.5.
throughout poomsae scoring so just remember accuracy is a 4.0 presentation is a 6.0 accuracy
is judge during your pattern presentation is after and then we get the two scores that we add up
and we get that number so with this one obviously uh say i was i was judge number one i would give
you a 6.2 there was another judge on the other side maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than i
did so maybe this one would be a little bit lower it might be a five point something another judge
on the other side they scored a little bit higher so we'd get three numbers and then we'd average
that as well so i hope this uh helped you guys so make sure you enjoy your poomsae competitions and
anytime we're gonna practice raping yourself
so minor errors while watching your own video you cannot pause
this time it's like you're being judged for yourself okay yeah and major errors and then
after the performance will be the power and speed coordination and expression of energy perfect so
i'm going to give you guys a little bit of time to do that and then we'll see you guys in the next
video so thank you so much for watching i hope you enjoyed this video and i'll see you guys in the
next video bye
Thank you.